it's cool to go back to those games that
were so brutally hard as a kid where I
couldn't even beat the first level and
learn how to dab salutely destroy the
games it took me very very long time to
even be able to beat Super Mario
Brothers for instance and now I have the
record of it
you may know me as Darby and on twitch
my name is Brad and I'm the world record
holder in Super Mario Brothers so the
goal of speedrunning is what the goal of
speedrunning is to go fast
it took me six thousand six hundred and
seven tries to set the record I can feel
my heart going kind of crazy in my chest
I get a little uncomfortable
I might notice my hands sweating more
I'll get antsy I'll hit a button too
early or too late or I'll try to play
too perfectly because I say I may never
get another opportunity like this I
better not blow it let's go all out I
think you need to be a very patient
person to speed run as you come closer
and closer to reaching the goal like you
get later and later in the particular
run these thoughts start going through
your head could this be it I hope I
don't screw this up the neat thing about
speedrunning is that the expected
outcome is failure and the better you
get at it the more you fail that was the
game there that's like 30 seconds off of
the record